[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is cherry flowers with Paige
and flowers and we're here in the urban
jungle st. Paul Minnesota in the Hamline
Midway neighborhood on a lot that's a
double lot and this is our urban farm
we've been growing for in it in the
urban landscape for about twelve years
on different sites around the city and
right here this is our home and also our
part of our farm in this farm site we
happen to have a high tunnel our high
tunnel is 30 by 32 the advantages of
having a high tunnel would be that you
can grow things for a longer period of
time throughout the season so starting
earlier in the spring and then going
later into the fall in the high tunnel
we usually grow things that like really
warm season temperature so we've grown
tomatoes peppers eggplant we've also
grown and we have in there now to some
sweet potatoes that like a longer season
and like hotter temperatures and then
right now we're experimenting with
ginger and turmeric that are hot season
types of crops and longer season crops
as well partly because they're
high-value crops and then other things
that we're doing in the high tunnel
aquaponics and hydroponics and
succession planting is another piece of
it so in the spring we might start with
lettuce or greens of some sort that like
the cool season weather and then move
into the hot season crops in the middle
of the year and then go into another
cool variety in the fall one of the
things about a high tunnel is that of
course because it's covered with plastic
you don't end up with rainwater getting
inside unless you work really hard at it
and we found out about the Sarah grant
and we were fortunate enough to get a
sare grant to do water capture off of
the high tunnel and the high tunnel will
it will capture about a total of 600
gallons of water and a one-inch rainfall
and so we felt like that was worth
working toward so what we put together
is gutters on both sides of the high
tunnel that collect the water and then
the water goes into rain barrels at the
west side of the high tunnel and from
there we have a pump and the pump is
powered either from our house from the
electricity from our house or by a solar
collector and then from there the water
is pumped through into a drip irrigation
system and in the irrigation system then
that runs directly to the roots of the
plants and that's important in a high
channel because if you have overhead
watering sometimes the leaves get wet
and they can get diseased so so this
whole system works really well together
and it's a way for us to take advantage
of all of the water that sheets off of
the high tunnel and it also helps us to
keep from from flooding the high tunnel
because originally when all the wires
would come off the high tunnel some of
it would get inside and then it would
tend to flood the edges of it and make
it too wet
[Music]